SPEAKER: Once your ML
model has been trained
and is ready to
make predictions,
you'll need to be
able to serve it.
Kubeflow Serving or KFServing
is a powerful open source tool
you can use to serve your
models with the scale
and performance of Kubernetes.
Let's look at how
KFServing gives you
an easy-to-use interface so you
can serve models in production.
To see the documentation
on KFServing,
check out the link below.
Kubernetes brings
powerful features
to training and
serving your ML models.
But it can be tricky to handle
the configuration of servers,
auto scaling, networking, and
health checks of Kubernetes
clusters to run your
models in production.
KFServing aims to
hide this complexity
to bring you a simple,
pluggable, and complete story
for our production ML serving.
This includes everything
from prediction
to pre-processing,
post-processing,
and explainability.
It gives you standard interfaces
for common ML frameworks
like TensorFlow, XGBoost,
Scikit Learn, and PyTorch,
giving you a
consistent experience
for models of all kinds.
Its interface is a YAML
file, typically checked
into a Git repository.
Simply point your
specification, or spec,
to a serialized model
file in cloud storage,
and you get a live model
at an HTTP end point.
On top of that,
KFServing lets you
leverage cutting-edge
production serving features,
like using GPUs, auto
scaling, scaling to zero,
and Canary rollouts to
your ML deployments.
KFServing is
installed by default
as part of a Chipotle
installation,
but you can also install
it as a standalone using
a quick script.
Check out the link
below to learn how.
Behind the scenes
KFServing is built
using the extensibility
of Kubernetes
and the layers that
sit on top of it.
Istio is a service
mesh layer that
takes care of the
load balancing,
security, and monitoring
of the micro services
that make up a
Kubernetes cluster.
It enables KFServing to handle
traffic routing and ingress
to your deployed model.
Knative is a layer that
lets you deploy and manage
serverless workloads
on Kubernetes.
It enables KFServing to handle
networking and Canary rollouts
so you can safely make
changes to your end point
without dropping any traffic.
And it even enables you to
auto scale GPUs and TPUs.
For ML scientists, this
means adding something
to the KFServing resource is as
simple as using the KFServing
interface that's
provided first class.
For example, when you want
to tweak min-max replicas
or perform a canary test.
For ML ops engineers, this
means applying policies
under the hood becomes
much more manageable
with the layered
Kubernetes architecture,
like when you want to apply
security policies, failure,
recovery metrics,
and monitoring.
Let's walk through
an example interface.
While you can create
a short YAML file
to quickly serve your
model and get an end point,
there are many ways you
can customize things
like authentication
and Canary rollouts.
Here the min and
max specs are a way
to control your provisioning
of back end pods
to make sure that you
don't drop requests.
And you can meet demand
without overspending.
Behind the scenes, Knative
handles routing and queuing
of traffic.
You can also specify resource
requests like selecting GPUs.
And thanks to Knative's
concurrency-based auto scalar,
you can effectively
scale CPUs or GPUs.
By default, KFServing sets
target concurrency to 1.
So if you load the service
with five concurrent requests,
the auto scalar will scale up to
five pods, and back down to one
when requests die down.
For most ML scientists, one
of the biggest challenges
is how to deploy
models in production
using Canary rollouts.
You want to be able to
easily test and update
your data models to production
without impacting users.
While traffic splitting to
back ends is a challenge,
KFServing lets you
slowly increment traffic
from an old model to
an experimental model.
In this example,
we're rolling out
a new version of an IRIS model.
As we slowly increment traffic
percentage to our B2 model,
we can be confident
that Canary isn't
going to disrupt our users.
Eventually, we'll move 100%
of traffic to our V2 model,
then delete the
original deployment,
allowing you to completely
manage the lifecycle of data
models in production.
When it comes to
processing data,
ML frameworks don't
give you a place
to execute code that
processes requests.
KFServing includes hooks so you
can provide your own container
implementations to do
pre and post processing.
You just need to add the hook
in your KFServing interface,
specify a container image spec
for your processing handler,
and KFServing
automatically wires it up.
The hook called
a transformer can
help you process requests, like
if you want to translate a user
ID into a set of new
features about the user.
These new features can then be
fed into another hook called
an explainer that can
perturb the features
and send prediction
requests to them.
Perturbing features to see
its effect on a model's output
is one way of explaining or
shedding light on your models.
Finally, the predictor can do
predictions on those requests,
post process them
in the transformer,
and send the transformer
requests back to you.
Together, these hooks
give you a simple way
to serve an end-to-end ML
model with explainability
at your fingertips.
KFServing gives you
out-of-the-box standardized
model serving across frameworks.
It's built for production
inferencing with features
like canarying, auto
scaling, explainability,
and a clean interface,
making it easy
for you to review models and
change config on the fly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]